何か はい  パンディタというのは阿羅漢っていう意味で
まあそのそろそろ取るしかないでしょう
この場合は阿羅漢で 前の偈ではアッターナン ダメ アンティ パンディタでしょ
まだ制御途中でしょ 阿羅漢にならないんですね
だから  その偈によって意味がちょっと違う
その偈によって取らなくちゃいけないと思います
だからそういうパンディタというと
パンニャーワンタというか
確実に一般の用語の場合はそこら辺ちょっと気をつけるんです
仏教用語の場合はもうはっきり意味を固定するんですね
パンディタっていうのは一般的な用語ですからね
まあスリランカではね
あの 何と言いますか 試験がありますよ
試験合格したらパンディタって言うんです
まあ例えば大学ではね
博士とかあるでしょ 博士
学士 修士とかね そんな感じで
パーリ サンスクリット
シンハラ語などなど そこら辺勉強して
その試験受かったらパンディタというタイトルをつけるんです
阿羅漢という意味じゃないんです
はい 他の質問ございますか？はいはい
思い出したくない嫌な過去のことばっかり思い出してしまって
それをやめたいと思うけど
やめられない 今日頭の中で考えていて
嫌な気分になってしまっているけれども
こういうのをどうやったら制御
その場合は別な思考で埋め込むでしょ
だから思い出したくないものを思い出したりするということは
頭は暇がある過ぎなんですよ
だから何か別なね 心清らかになる本でも読んで
これはどういうことやとかね
別なことに頭忙しくするんです
それを置き換え論理と言うんです
仏教では 悪いものは良いことで置き換える
やめようやめようと言ってもできないんですよ
心はどうしても回転しなくちゃあかんだからね
だから明るい思考が入れてあげないと暗い思考で回転しちゃうんですよ
そういうふうなことで置き換えをしてください
はい でははい  神を信じる宗教を広めること
信じることというのは
やはり悪い行為にはならないのでしょうか
その悪い行為それを広めることを悪い行為をしているということは
悪い行為だとすれば そのことを続けることはやがて悪い結果をもたらす
一応その教え広げて悪い結果になっていますから
世界中ね だからそういうことは世界論で問題はね
本人が本当に信じているのかという 第1
だから広げて宣伝する場合はしつこく
あなた本当に信じているのかとかね
どんな証拠なのかと聞くと
本人は優柔不断になるならば
本人は悪いことをしているんです
頭がイカれてでも構いません
本人がやっぱり私は断言的に信仰していると言ったら
まあどうしようもないんですよ
自分が信じることを広げるのはね
しかし それだけで悪いとは決められません
神はいないのに嘘を言って信じさせても
あなた方は良いことをしなさいよと
人を愛しなさいよと 貧しい人々を助けなさいということも教えているならば
そのポイントでは良いことなんですね
だから 宗教によって道徳がやばい状態になるならば
断言的に悪い 宗教が悪いなのに道徳がしっかりしてくれるならば
例えば私たちは何も信仰がなくて宇宙ぶらりんの状態で
そういう人にあんた神がいるんだから気をつけなさいと言った時点から気をつけるようになったならば
神が見張ってるんだからやばいと
それで本人がある幻覚に引っかかって道徳を守っているんですね
その時点では悪いとは言えないんですね
だから断言的な答えはできません
判断する基準は道徳なんです
私は個人的な経験と一般論ではあまり合わない
個人的な経験でいうと
宣伝する人に限って信じてないんです
だからある一時期あったんですよ
アメリカから来て 若者グループがもう宗教活動に来てね
結局は信じてないんです
もう現代社会の知識には対応できない
それですごく精神的に困ったりして
もう仕事にも身が入らないしね
だからまあいいやと 私はそのグループをね
自分の部屋に呼んで いろいろものを教えてあげたり
疲れがなくなるように
気分が穏やかになるように一生懸命助けたこともあるんです
だから 朝出て行って あっちこっちで宣伝活動して
クタクタ疲れて ものすごく嫌な気分で
で そうなったら必ず私の部屋に人好き寄ってきて
自分のところに戻るんです
私はもうそんなへんてこりんなことを信仰しても何ともないんですけど
その人々のこと 若者でしょうし
あまり日本語も喋れないし
ほとんど喋れないしね
まあだからなんとか自分にできる範囲のことを助けてあげるということで
それでどんどん いくら何でもね
この人々には世間の知識を教えてあげなくちゃということで
いくらアメリカ人であってもと
で 私はいろいろ文章を書いていたんだからね
文章を一つあげたら あんたこれ読んでみて
感想を言ってくださいと
そしたら 2週間経ってから辞書がなくて
まだまだちょっとまだ読んでないんだと言うんですね
だから私は外人で 英語で書いた文章は本人が辞書ないで読めないというならば
やっぱり教育問題の問題なんですね
まあどうせそうでしょう
こちらはもう大学の仕事をしていてね
向こうはおそらく普通のね
若者でしょうしね だからそれはしょうがないんですけど
まあ読んでも理解しないでしょうと思ったんですね
やっぱり学問的なレベルではね
まあこれだったらと思ったんですけど
まあいい青年たちでしたからね
結構仲良く友達としてはね
まあ日本出るまでは面倒は見たんですけど
私は宗教ね だからこういうことをいろいろ見ると
もう伝道する人に限って信じてないという面白い現象なんです
一般の西洋人と喋ると
宗教ではなくて学風そ結構真面目に信じてる人々はいたんですね
でも面白くない ただ迷信で信じるんですね
ある女性がね 教頭に学生で来て泊まっていた人
それもアメリカ人の女性でね
やっぱり自分が本気で信じていますよと
という シリアスに信じてるんだと言ったんですね
そしたら私はそれをどういうことかと聞いたら
何か事故とか何かあって
本人が助かったという話なんです
だから私は心の中で だったら信じない方が正しいでしょうにと思ったのに
だって事故を起こして
独り善児自分が助かって
だから神様がいるんだぞって話じゃないでしょうに
[笑い]うん やっぱり迷信だなとね
迷信だったらもう話になりませんだから
私はよかったね それは
と言って それで終わったんです
そういうことで  まあある面で無知かもしれませんだけど
正直かと私は何で聞くのかというと
正直に信仰する阿呆が
我々は地獄に落ちると本気で思っているんです
永遠な地獄に落ちると
だから そこから何とか抜け出したいという気持ちだけはね
あんまり悪い気持ちでもないんです
だから 伝道する人が正直に信じてるかなんかっていうことを徹底的にもう押して押していきなさいと私は言ったらそういうわけなんです
それで聞いたところで
もうお手上げ これはもう幻覚的で
もう陥って もう治らないんだと
この神の信仰はと 分かったならば
本人はあまり悪いことをしているつもりじゃないんですね
かわいそうに 永遠な地獄から何とかしてあげ
落ちることから何とかしてあげようと思っているだけになっちゃうんですね
その分だけ微妙に まあ生命に
生命を心配するということになる
でも 永遠という言葉自体成り立たない
そんなのわかるわけないで
そういう人々には はい
そういうことで 世の中でいろいろ信仰あるんだからね
どちらかというと どちらか間違ったことを一般人に言えたものでもないし
だからそんなのはどうでもいいっていうことで
イスラム教であろうが
キリスト教であろうが
もうモルモン教であろうが
エホバの証人であろうが
もう勝手にしろよと そういう人々が世の中にみんな一応道徳を守って
秩序を守る人間になるために何か貢献するならば
その分は評価するべきなんですね
それだけなんです 話は
はい ではまだ質問あった？なかったような感じがします
はいはい  賢者がですね
こういうことにですね
動じないと  うん  言うのであればですね
我々が子供を育てたり
人に仕事をしてもらう時に褒めてやる気を出して喜ばせると
そういうモチベーションでやらせることがありますけど
それはあんまり上等な手段じゃないと
いいえ それは世間のことだから
その人は賢者じゃないでしょうに
だから賢者にそういうふうに煽てても意味がないんです
賢者はやるんですよ 仕事は
頼んでも頼まなくてもやるべき仕事を淡々とやる
それで周りがすごく喜ぶんです
結果として 賢者でない人はね
褒めてあげないとやらないで子供は明らかでしょうに
ちょっともういい ちょっといいことだけ見て褒めるんで
自分が知ってても悪いこともやったなと
それは知らんふり まあ私もよくやりますよ
いろいろ悪いことするんですけど
それは知ってないことにするんですね
聞いてないことにしたりして
もういいことだけ いいことしてるんで
してるんではないかとかね
言ったりする だからそこはすぐ乗っちゃってね
バレなかったとかね やっぱりそういうのはやめましょうとか
向こうは勝手に思うんです
まあ結局こちらの思い過ごなんですけど
まあそれは普通の世界のことでね
しかし我々は賢者の位置が一番最高だから
そこを目指すべきなんですよ
例えば自分がそうなさってるかもしれませんだけど
自分にも同じことやらせる
やらされてるでしょ？褒めてもらったりとかね
はい これに関してですね
子供の頃ちょっと思ったんですけども
褒められて先生たちは何かやらせようとするんですけど
褒められて何かそそのかされて動くっていうのはなんかかっこ悪いなっていう風に思い始めた時がありました
それを考えると自分はそうだったんで
積極的に人には褒めてやらせるというのは何か変かなって
あのね 褒めるではなくて評価するというね
言葉を入れ替えてください
評価する それが仏教は認めるんです
しっかりと評価する だから褒めたい気分があったら
まあちょっと今日は余分に評価してあげますと
言うと相手が気持ち通じるんですね
やっぱり自分がやったことは認めてるんだと
評価することなんですね
それはもう悪いことじゃないんです
褒めると言えば ちょっと怪しい言葉なんですね
はっきりしないんですね
仏教が使う単語は評価する
アプリシエイトする 褒めるという単語ではないんです
プライスではないんですね
褒めると英語でプライスですね
神を褒めるとかね プライス大号とか言ったりするでしょうね
これがもう無知な人にいろいろやらせるために乗せるためにやることで
神はいいんです 無知だから
で 人間の場合は仏教でアプリシエート
例えば奥さんの仕事をアプリシエートする
褒めなくてもいいんです
あんたすごいですね 美人ですねとか殴られるかもしれません
しかし アプリシエートすると大変疲れがなくなって
やった価値がありましたとという充実感が生まれてくる
充実感も大事なんです
そういう風に調整すればいいんじゃないかなと思います
はい  今パターンのご質問にちょっと逆の立場でして
賢者は批判と賞賛に動じない
はい 賢者でない私は賞賛賞賛に動じないように気を付けることができます
うん で 批判を受けた時に動じないのはいけないんじゃないかと思います
はい 実際に動じもします
うん 動じる 動じないといけないのに動じないこともあります
どういうふうにこの批判を受けた時に
賢者でない私がどういう態度を取ったら
あるいはどうこうしたらどう思われたらいいのでしょうか
はいはい 大事なポイントあります
その質問に私もそれ言おう言おうと思っていたんです
本当は で 褒め称えてくれると動じないでいることが正しいんです
しかし いろいろ批判したり
いろんなことを言われたりすると
いきなり無視するそう
動じないそうっていうことはちょっと危険かも
なぜかというと 私たちに見えない我々の間違っているところが
他人にはものすごく明確に見えちゃいますからね
人間というのは人の悪いところしか見てないでしょ
だから世間は随分勝手で
人の悪いところだけもういちいちハイライトして喋るんですよ
その場合はちょっと聞いた方がいいかもしれませんね
あ あら そういえばそういうところ私にあるんだと
そういう風にこの批判の場合はある程度で聞いた方がいいということはあります
そこは役に立ちます で
なんで役に立つのかというと
世間様っていうのは人の悪いことばっかり見ているんですね
マスコミ見たらわかるでしょう
誰かが失敗したらものすごく大騒ぎ
待ってるんですね 誰かが不幸になるまで
もうそれでも励ましみたいな感じでね
だからそこは悪いというんじゃなくて
置いといて 自分たちの自分が気づかない
自分が気づかない いろいろ微妙なところが
みんなギャーギャー言うと
もうちょっと気をつけて
あ なるほど そういうところは考えた方が良い
理解するのは正しいんです
しかし 動じないということも必要です
なぜかというと 批判したら
なんで嫌だ なんでこんなこと言われなくちゃあかんかとかね
そういう感情的になったら困るんですよ
もう自信もなくなったとかね
仕事をする勇気もなくなったとか
もう外へ出ることもできなくなったとかね
これが恐ろしい あ そう
あそうと言いながら  なんかポイントありそうやと心の中で
そういえばちょっと引っかかるところあるんだなと自分で知った方がよろしいと思います
それで賢者でない我々はどんどん良い人間になっていくんです
ムカッとしない  そうそうそうそう
ムカッとしたらん？と思うんですね
はい ありがとうございます
はい すいません 今のお話の中で
人の悪いところをばっかり見るのは
私も人の欠点とか悪いところばっか見えて
そしてそれで自分で心を汚してるんですけれども
人に直接言わなくても
あの人はこうだ この人はこうだと思ったりもしてるんですけど
それを汚さないようにするために
その人の欠点を見るときどうしたらいいでしょうか
やっぱり人にはいいところもありますから
だから頭がはっきり言えば頭が悪いことなんですよ
欠点ばっかり見るのはね
自分が正しいというものすごく恐ろしい前提があるんですよ
それある限り人は成長しませんね
正しいんだから成長する必要ないでしょう
だから それはとっても危険なことなんです
我は正しいと思うこと
しかし これはあってはならない
もう極限に邪見なんです
それで我々は極限に邪見にいるんだから
人の欠点は簡単に見えちゃうんですね
そうなってくると 別な例で言えば
世間の臭いゴミを取っては入れる
取っては入れる 取っては入れるという
自分の心に だからもうたくさん美しいものがある
例えば花ばっかり咲いてるでっかい公園に行っても
ちょっと犬のフンがあって
そこだけ心を中に入れてるだけで
自分には犬のフンしか見えてないんです
何百万も花が咲いているのに見えてないという
だからかわいそうな 邪見は
その場でそういう極限な苦しみの世界を作ってくるんです
だから人間みんなやってるんだからといって正しいやり方じゃないんです
だから人格者っていうのは
まず私はどうったことない
もうただのだらしない欠点だらけのもう話にならん人間だと
まず事実を認めるんです
それでもうあの人にはこんないいところあるんだとかね
私ならこの場合怒るんだけど
この人はなぜ怒ってないんだとかね
例えば店のね いろいろセールスマンとか見ると
時々買う買うつもりもなく
何時間もセールスマンを引っ張ってあれやこれやと聞いたり聞いたりするでしょ
それも私は見ていてね
どう見たっても この人は物は買わないし
他のお客さんに対応できないようにしているんではないかと見えるんですよ
忙しいなのに その人を取って捕まってね
それで私はその若者セールスマンの顔を見るんですね
どんな対応してるのかと
何のことなく すごい冷静に
ずっともう相手がもう納得いって店が出るまで頑張って
最後にありがとうございますと言うと
あ すごいいい性格だなと
よくできてる人だなと
やっぱり私もあまりちょっと気をつけた方がいいんじゃないかなと思ったりするんです
だから そういうふうに人のいいところ見ると
すごい気分がいいんです
だから私は正しいという極限的な邪見をもうなんとか潰さないと
それ潰したらもう人の良いところ見えるようになります
当然人っていうのは不完全だから良いところばっかりでもないし
悪いところばっかりでもないんです
だからできれば良いところを見えるならば
その人にとっては人生は楽しい
敵がなくなっちゃうんです
悪い人でも その人に会うと
その人は悪いところ見てないんだから気分がいいんですよ